[Música]
la Corte Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos se escucha hoy una demanda de la
comunidad indígena ua contra el estado
colombiano Al que acusa de haber
vulnerado su derecho a administrar su
territorio concretamente alegan como
durante años se ha aprobado la
explotación petrolera y la extracción de
gas en estas tierras sin su
consentimiento para conocer más a fondo
la situación y esta disputa legal
saludamos desde el municipio de cubara
en Colombia a Juan tegría él es
integrante de la comunidad uba y además
asesor jurídico de asowa señor te quería
Bienvenido a France 24 empecemos por el
contexto de esta demanda Cómo llega este
caso a la corte y cómo ha sido el
proceso con el estado colombiano
gracias Buenos días y bueno en el caso
de la de la demanda que nosotros lo
subas tenemos a nivel internacional que
inicialmente se presenta el 28 de abril
del 97 ante la Comisión Interamericana
de Derechos Humanos se da por la
vulneración de derechos territoriales
culturales que el estado colombiano
perpetua contra la nación uva
ese es un contexto en el que nosotros
hemos solicitado digamos el apoyo de la
comisión ahora en la corte para que
puedan fallar a favor de nosotros en la
reivindicación de nuestros derechos
ahora qué medidas específicas están
solicitando ustedes para remediar esta
situación y proteger sus territorios
digamos que inicialmente la la demanda
está por lo por la vulneración de de
nuestro derecho territorial el tema del
saneamiento del saneamiento territorial
es decir a nosotros nos dieron un un
resguardo Unido uva Sí y este resguardo
desde el 99 desde 1999 hasta la fecha no
ha sido saneado otro de los puntos
claves es el tema del bloque
exploratorio samoré el bloque significa
tlaya campo de gas Gibraltar El paso del
oleoducto cañón limón coveñas todo sobre
la las estribaciones de nuestro
resguardo el área de perforación
Magallanes que es otra prospección
petrolera que tiene la compañía
petrolera aquí en Colombia y la zona de
traslape que es una zona donde
digamos con el parque natural el Cucuy
el son 92 mil hectáreas que en estos
momentos la titulación la tiene parques
Aunque hace parte del del resguardo
Unido uva así como unos títulos mineros
dentro del dentro del resguardo y con y
esto conlleva una militarización y uso
de la fuerza en nuestro territorio y Qué
medidas hemos tomado nosotros Bueno hay
unas medidas legales que se
interpusieron en su tiempo en 1995 y
ganamos una acción de tutela que es una
es una medida judicial aquí en Colombia
y
la corte constitucional en ese momento
falló a favor de nosotros
el el consejo de estado falló en contra
de nosotros hubo choque de trenes y por
eso se llevó el proceso ante la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos en el
97 ya en el año dos mil dos mil el
aceite H presentó el caso ante la Corte
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos y en
el 2021 prácticamente se somete el
proceso del caso uva ante la Corte
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos señor
toda esta situación que usted menciona
ha provocado efectos perjudiciales para
ustedes De qué manera la explotación de
estos territorios ha impactado por
ejemplo en sus comunidades es decir
Cuáles han sido las consecuencias
sociales culturales económicas y además
ambientales que Ustedes han vivido y
además les ha tocado ver
bueno las consecuencias sociales
prácticamente son de tipo
de de migración y también de problemas
internos dentro de nuestras comunidades
Esta es una zona muy álgida con el tema
de conflicto armado Sí entonces
diferentes actores pues a veces
incursionan dentro de nuestro territorio
como el eructo cañón coveñas pasa por la
mitad del resguardo Unido uva pues han
habido voladuras al heloducto Y eso trae
una contaminación ambiental Y
prácticamente hay caños ríos que quedan
sin sin poder utilizarse se mueren los
peces esto ha traído también
enfermedades de la piel enfermedades
gastrointestinales para los menores ha
sido una situación difícil para nosotros
digamos hemos tenido también problemas
de poco reconocimiento por parte del
Estado porque esta es una zona muy
abandonada de de parte de del Estado
colombiano es una zona olvidada ahí
Tenemos también el tema de una lucha
pronta una lucha
se puede decir frontal contra el estado
porque las vías de acceso para nuestro
resguardo y fuera de nuestro resguardo
también son son mínimas no hay una
participación por parte del Estado en
apoyo a la salud ha sido bastante
complicada la situación menciona usted
el señor trujilla una correlación en
estos proyectos petroleros y el
conflicto armado en Colombia Cómo se ha
desarrollado esta situación
Pues el desarrollo digamos que nosotros
estamos en contra de la exploración
explotación petrolera por digamos por
usos y costumbres Sí y por tradición
espiritual y cultural porque resulta que
ruidía es decir el petróleo es la sangre
de la madre tierra siempre lo hemos
manifestado nosotros los uvas la sangre
de la madre tierra debe estar adentro
dentro de sus venas no por fuera estando
por fuera trae problemas problemas con
los cuales entonces
lo que usted acaba de mencionar con el
tema de los grupos armados con el tema
las migraciones de otras personas de
porque la prospección petrolera trae
migraciones de personas de otros lugares
y se genera todo una mixtura digamos de
de personas dentro de todo ese contexto
territorial
arrinconando arrinconando a las uvas a
otras estribaciones bueno Y ahora cómo
esperan ustedes que este caso repercuten
el derecho a la autodeterminación de los
pueblos indígenas a decidir sobre sus
territorios Sí bueno la situación
digamos que parte desde el
reconocimiento del bloque de
constitucionalidad y la misma
Constitución Nacional de Colombia es un
artículo séptimo reconoce a los pueblos
indígenas y el convenio 169 de la uitec
nos da ese nos da ese reconocimiento
internacional y lo que nosotros
esperamos es que ese reconocimiento sea
real sí que ese reconocimiento tenga una
repercusión sí a nivel nacional y a
nivel internacional que se oiga la voz
de los pueblos indígenas que nuestra
propia autodeterminación o digamos
autonomía para tomar decisiones internas
frente a nuestro territorio sea una
realidad todo parte por el tema de la
consulta previa resulta que nosotros en
el en el año de 1995 supuestamente
occidental de Colombia y en ese momento
las empresas petroleras y que tienen a
su prospección en nuestro territorio y
nos consultaron en el en el fondo no
hubo ninguna consulta Entonces qué
buscamos nosotros primero que se respete
nuestro territorio ancestral nuestro
territorio legalmente constituido que
nosotros tengamos digamos la la forma de
decidir no decidir cómo vamos a morir
porque ellos hablan dicen la consulta
previa es el máximo derecho que tienen
las comunidades indígenas pero en
últimas si uno se sienta con las
empresas petroleras estado colombiano no
no hay ninguna ninguna decisión que
nosotros podamos tomar es decir No hay
derecho al veto bien nosotros estaremos
saltando entonces a Cómo se desarrolla
este proceso legal allí en la Corte
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
juantería integrante de la comunidad
urugua jurídico de asowa Gracias por
acompañarnos aquí en directo a México
y hacemos una breve pausa ya regresamos
con más aquí en directo América
[Música]